Superman is an American icon, and while the
character is criticized for not being as edgy
as some of his super-colleagues, not just
anyone can play him.
For truth, justice, and the Hollywood way,
here are our thoughts on the best and worst
choices for actors to replace Henry Cavill
as Superman.
Best: Matt Bomer
White Collar's Matt Bomer was considered an
early candidate for Man of Steel, and he actually
voiced the alien superhero that year in Superman:
Unbound.
Before that, Bomer was cast as Superman before
Brandon Routh in what eventually became Superman
Returns.
According to HuffPost, the same year Bomer
publicly came out as gay at an awards ceremony,
author Jackie Collins claimed that he was
ousted from the role because of it.
Undoubtedly, Bomer has the looks and the acting
chops to play Superman.
Plus, he's already been cast as Superman — twice!
Worst: Nicolas Cage
Believe it or not, a growing number of people
want Nicolas Cage to get another shot at the
role of the Last Son of Krypton.
Cage was famously cast in Tim Burton's Superman
Lives, which was never finished because, well,
sometimes the universe is kind.
Let's be honest.
Cage is too old, Warner Brothers probably
wants people to actually go see their new
Superman movies, and — unless they're planning
a nontraditional, dystopian Superman film
— Superman is not insane.
Best: Armie Hammer
One of the names that's coming up more than
others is Cavill's Man from U.N.C.L.E.
co-star Armie Hammer.
He was cast as Batman in George Miller's unrealized
Justice League: Mortal, and according to The
Hollywood Reporter's blog Heat Vision, he
was also one of the final contenders for Man
of Steel's Superman role before it went to
Cavill.
Hammer would be a perfect fit.
He's got the height.
He's got the physique.
And as proven by the well-deserved praise
for his work in 2017's Call Me by Your Name,
he's got the talent.
Worst: John Krasinski
Even though John Krasinski isn't at the top
of a lot of lists to replace Cavill, Mark
Hughes of Forbes thinks he's the perfect choice.
Perhaps it's the product of typecasting, but
it's difficult to imagine Krasinski as Superman.
Hughes' comparison of Krasinski's character
on The Office to Clark Kent is more than apt,
and that's the problem.
It isn't difficult at all to see Krasinski
as Kent, but it feels almost impossible to
see him portraying the other half of that
iconic duality.
His work in A Quiet Place and Jack Ryan notwithstanding,
Krasinski seems like the guy who plays the
one who's being saved, not the one who's doing
the saving.
Best: Michael B. Jordan
It didn't take long at all for reports to
surface that Warner Brothers already had a
frontrunner to replace Cavill as Superman,
and if it pans out, it would arguably be the
most nontraditional and bold Superman casting
choice to date: Black Panther's Michael B.
Jordan.
Continuously proving himself to be a stellar
actor with huge range, Jordan's one of the
premiere reasons Black Panther is an Oscar
contender.
And as anyone who's had to hear their partner
talk about Jordan going shirtless can attest,
we know he's got the physique.
Worst: Dwayne Johnson
The Rock's name is popping up as a potential
candidate for obvious reasons — he sells
tickets, he's got the body for it, and as
USA Today said,
"He is Superman, after all."
However, Dwayne Johnson's commitments to play
the antihero Black Adam would make playing
Superman in the same narrative difficult.
And while Superman is big, muscular, and larger-than-life
just like Johnson, he's also extremely humble,
and Johnson just may not be that guy.
In fact, if Warner Brothers decided to go
in a different physical direction for Superman's
classic nemesis, Johnson could make a great
Lex Luthor.
He already has the hairdo.
Best: Colin O'Donoghue
According to The Hollywood Reporter's blog
Heat Vision, Once Upon a Time's Colin O'Donoghue
was one of the actors competing with Cavill
for the role of Superman in 2013's Man of
Steel.
The Irish Post reported that O'Donoghue is
now an early frontrunner to replace him.
O'Donoghue is a good choice, but not a perfect
one.
He certainly has the acting ability and the
looks to play Superman.
But he also has a natural mischievous quality
that you wouldn't ordinarily associate with
the Man of Steel.
While he would do well in Superman's tights,
you'd almost wonder if he might do better
in Lex Luthor's office.
Worst: Tyler Hoechlin
DC Comics fans were thrilled when Tyler Hoechlin
appeared as Superman in the second season
of Supergirl, and many Arrowverse viewers
seem convinced this is the perfect job for
him.
But whether or not you like Hoechlin's take
on the Man of Steel, someone already playing
Superman in another live-action medium with
a different storyline should not be the guy
who replaces Cavill.
Having two live-action Supermen played by
two different men is probably confusing enough.
Casting the same guy in both roles?
Forget it.
Best: Henry Golding
Crazy Rich Asians star Henry Golding has emerged
as one of the leading contenders to play Superman
in any future DCEU projects, and the choice
has promise.
He's a rising star in Hollywood with good
looks and a warm likability — and he's getting
a lot of attention right now.
Add to that the fact that Warner Brothers
has been making some very public statements
recently about their commitment to diversity,
and Golding seems like he has a real shot
at those blue tights if he wants them.
Worst: Rob Delaney
Comedian Rob Delaney jokingly threw his hat
in the ring for the new Superman the same
day it was reported that Cavill was out, tweeting,
"Heard they're in the market for a new Superman.
How sexy are they looking to go?"
While Delaney's Deadpool 2 role certainly
highlighted his flying skills, it's highly
unlikely that he's a serious contender.
Still, it would almost be worth hearing Deadpool
complain about Warner Brothers poaching the
comedian from his franchise if all it meant
was enduring Delaney as Superman for a film
or two.